je suis
un homme de petite taille
à
34,73
je m'aperçois que j'ai une belle vie que
j'ai une très belle vie malgré le
handicap de sa petite taille
m brice et sam acquérir ce qu'on appelle
un à coudre place cette maladie
congénitale empêche le développement
normal des membres inférieurs et
supérieurs
son père médecin général tend à
l'impossible pour le faire grandir mais
vers l'âge de 5 ans il fallu se rendre à
l'évidence ses cartilages de conjugaison
étant soudés l'enfant deviendrait un
homme de petite taille j'étais considéré
comme une sorte de drap d'or maria qui
devaient supporter toutes les bizarres
toutes les méchancetés que l'on peut
imaginer
vis-à-vis d'un enfant pas comme tout le
monde enfin on m'a fait des misères vous
savez at roche
g chercham suicide
privilégiée malgré tout par sa naissance
dans une famille aisée et compréhensive
jean-brice et saint macary à l'âge de 43
ans épouse suzanne tessier une
infirmière donc il aura trois enfants
seul l'aîné marie-antoinette survivra en
faisant de lui le grand père heureux de
pascal et laurence et deux petits
enfants parallèlement à sa vie affective
la carrière de jean brice et saint
macary sera brillante bachelier avec
mention docteur en droit à 26 ans avec
un premier prix au concours des thèses
conseiller au ministère de la justice
pourtant comme son père le lui a demandé
jean-brice et saint macary sera notée
rural connu de tous dans son village sa
silhouette est devenue familière et on
accepte d'autant plus que par ses
capacités intellectuelles et son métier
il peut rendre de grands services
l'être humain
lettre d'un certain âge
peut être très cruel
vis-à-vis d'un enfant même des femmes
c'est certain que ce sont des femmes de
fort belles femmes que j'ai pu croiser
dans mon existence qui ont été pts et
pris les publient ça que j'ai reçu dans
mon existence
aujourd'hui m brice et saint macary
notaire retraité se consacre au service
de la cause de ses frères handicapés
pour cette raison il a accepté la
présidence de ce premier congrès des
maires l'objectif obtenir l'intégration
des êtres de petite taille dans la
société les aider dans leur vie
quotidienne voire familiales pour ceux
qui veulent se marier et avoir des
enfants
on veut pas rencontrer sur son chemin
bien des personnes capables d'envisager
un mariage avec notre criirad être de
petite taille mais il faut reconnaître
que la femme a un esprit de charité de
bon team dit jean un mois et chaque fac
tu parles de charité nécessitant parle
je pense que on ne se marie pas par
charité
je suis apprécié et gtb quelques épis
alors quand du culte doit aussi qu'on
paie ses dires je suis il est alors le
jour du passé à la télévision et une
taxe acquittée après que dit cet homme
est beau le sache pour bercy donner
ainsi parce que je veux qu il ya eu
tellement de personnes qui m'ont fait
comprendre le contraire qu'il faut
trouver une âme comme la tienne aussi
généreuse avoue qu'à l'heure actuelle ça
décale femme
est
elle consciente surtout venant de droit
[Musique]